the way that supplements are regulated
in this country is they're not they say
if you don't take our supplement your
immune system is going to suffer this is
where they lie vitamin C is crucial to
your immune system absolutely true if I
cut out all vitamin C out of your diet
your immune system would be shot very
true eating the diet that most people
that live the way you live you have
plenty of vitamin C and you'll never get
to that deficiency but what these
supplement companies promise to you is
by giving you more you'll somehow get a
bigger benefit that's not true once you
meet the minimum requirement of what you
need that's it your body doesn't need
anymore